Millions of film fans hold special places
in their hearts for Forrest, Jenny, Lieutenant
Dan, and the rest of the unforgettable characters
of Forrest Gump.
But what happened to the ensemble in the years
since 1994?
We've taken a look back to find out what these
stars have been up to.
Let's start with the obvious: Tom Hanks, already
an Oscar-winning mega-star when he played
Forrest Gump, hasn't exactly vanished from
view.
Hanks executive-produced the Emmy-winning
HBO miniseries Band of Brothers, played two
American heroes in Captain Phillips and Sully,
voiced a neurotic cowboy in Pixar's Toy Story
franchise, and also became the star of Saturday
Night Live's most memorable, baffling Halloween
skit.
"Any questions?"
The award-winning actor also remains half
of one of Hollywood's most long standing marriages
with wife Rita Wilson, with the two having
been married since 1988.
He's gained a reputation as one of the loveliest
people in Hollywood, and he has a hobby of
collecting vintage typewriters.
Robin Wright was hardly an unknown when she
scored her role in Forrest Gump.
Her role on the daytime drama Santa Barbara
had already earned her tons of fans, and she
also starred in cult fairytale favorite The
Princess Bride.
But for whatever reason, Wright spent the
next two decades flying way under the radar.
It's surprising that the role that made her
a household name is one she landed at the
age of 46, the ambitious, brilliant, Claire
Underwood on Netflix's House of Cards.
Offscreen, Wright has become an outspoken
advocate and spokesperson for Pour Les Femmes,
a sleepwear company that educates and employs
women in conflict regions around the world.
Most of the main folks in Forrest Gump have
gone on to have long and storied acting careers,
but Michael Conner Humphreys is an exception.
After what could have been a breakout performance
as young Forrest, Humphreys instead quit acting
entirely and took a different path, joining
the Army.
He served four years as an infantry soldier,
with his service including an 18-month tour
of duty in Iraq.
According to an interview with the Daily Mail,
he tried to keep his brief stint in Hollywood
a secret, but it didn't take long for his
fellow servicemembers to figure it out and
give him the nickname of "Gump."
Humphreys made a belated return to acting
in the 2010s, playing a soldier in the 2011
indie film Pathfinders: In the Company of
Strangers, and he also scored a role on the
2019 TV series Knight's End.
In a 2015 interview, he was said to be living
back in his birthplace of Independence, Mississippi,
where he pursued a college degree in international
relations.
"Run, Forrest!
Run!"
That's Hanna Hall's biggest contribution to
the cultural zeitgeist.
At the age of nine, she became known for shouting
what became Forrest Gump's most quotable line,
but she's also worked regularly ever since.
As a teen, she scored roles in Sofia Coppola's
The Virgin Suicides and the 2007 remake of
Halloween, and in more recent years she appeared
in guest roles on Criminal Minds and Masters
of Sex.
Despite having grown up a lot since her Forrest
Gump performance, Hall is still occasionally
recognized on the street by sharp-eyed fans
who ask her to repeat her famous catchphrase.
But she's said she doesn't know how to do
that Alabama accent anymore, so if you happen
to see her, just don't ask.
Sally Field was already a multiple Oscar winner
and A-lister when she played the tenacious
matriarch of the Gump family.
Her legacy as an actor was rock solid no matter
what she did after Forrest Gump.
But where is she now?
After spending several years as a Primetime
Emmy-award-winning guest star on ER, she joined
the ABC drama Brothers and Sisters, for which
she won another Emmy.
She also turned up in the role of Aunt May
in the Amazing Spider-Man movies, opposite
Andrew Garfield.
In 2017, she earned critical acclaim for playing
the challenging role of Amanda Wingfield in
a Broadway revival of The Glass Menagerie,
while 2018 saw her take on a key supporting
role in the Netflix series Maniac.
Basically, she's keeping plenty busy as she
rounds the corner on her seventh decade.
In Sally Field's storied career, Forrest Gump
is just a footnote.
After his remarkable turn as Forrest Gump's
BFF Bubba Blue, Mykelti Williamson has stayed
busy in Hollywood, consistently working smaller
parts on the big and small screens.
Among his more prominent appearances are a
regular role on Justified that spanned three
seasons, a role in the political thriller
series 24, and more.
Williamson seems to specialize in playing
police officers and military men, although
he did run afoul of the law when he played
Baby-O in the cult favorite Con Air.
And don't think he's given up serious award-season
fare: in 2016, he was part of the cast in
the Oscar-nominated Fences, directed by Denzel
Washington.
Unlike some of his co stars, Williamson has
fully embraced his legacy as a Forrest Gump
cast member.
On Instagram, he's even celebrated his character's
signature seafood obsession with "Shrimp Saturday",
in which he posts shrimp-related selfies and
solicits pictures of shrimp from fans around
the globe.
Gary Sinise has had no shortage of high-profile
projects since Forrest Gump, including repeated
reunions with Tom Hanks.
The two appeared together in Apollo 13 in
1996 and again in The Green Mile in 1999.
On the small screen, Sinise has found a comfortable
home in primetime procedural drama, playing
Detective Mac Taylor in the CSI franchise
from 2004 through 2013, then taking over in
a lead role in the Criminal Minds franchise
in 2016.
In a fitting turn, considering his military
"experience" in Forrest Gump, Sinise has become
a prominent supporter of American servicemembers.
He's lended his talents as a narrator to various
military documentaries, entertained troops
with the Lieutenant Dan Band, and created
his own philanthropic organization, the Gary
Sinise Foundation, to support servicemembers
once they're back home on U.S. soil.
Sinise has also been one of the few openly
Republican celebrities in Hollywood, founding
a group for conservative actors known as the
"Friends of Abe" in 2004 and supporting John
McCain's 2008 presidential campaign.
However, he disassociated himself from the
organization prior to the 2016 election, and
his online presence makes it clear that apart
from acting, his real priority is supporting
the troops.
The sleazy principal who admitted Forrest
to the public school system in exchange for
a roll in the hay with Mrs. Gump will be forever
remembered for his awkward, well… this.
But when it comes to this actor, you're more
likely to recognize him from the TV roles
that followed.
From 2005 through 2010, Anderson was a series
regular on Lost in the role of the kind-hearted
crash survivor Bernard, and if you didn't
catch him in that, you might know him as the
cold-hearted Lee Paxton on Justified.
But as ubiquitous as he is onscreen, the actor
keeps a low profile off camera.
He's been married to the same woman since
1985, is the father of twins, and in his spare
time, he likes to write mysteries.
In short, Anderson has gone on from Forrest
Gump to become what seems like the lifestyle
of an average retired dad… except that he's
also one of the hardest-working character
actors of his generation.
If you've seen Forrest Gump, you'll recognize
Afemo Omilami as the frothing drill sergeant
who complimented Forrest's intelligence, sort
of.
"You must have a g--damn IQ of 160.
You are g--damn gifted, Private Gump."
The drill sergeant role was only a bit part
for Omilami, who was already a Hollywood veteran
when Forrest Gump was made.
Omilami has appeared in multiple projects
every year dating all the way back to 1990.
Most recently, he held a major role in True
Detective and appeared as the Mayor of District
11 in The Hunger Games: Catching Fire.
And despite his busy work schedule, Omilami
also helps to run Hosea Feed the Hungry, an
Atlanta-based charitable organization designed
to combat homelessness and food scarcity.
It's practically the end of the movie before
he appears on screen, but he's there.
Before he saw dead people, Haley Joel Osment
made his big-screen debut in the tiny role
of Forrest Junior.
Needless to say, it was a good jumping-off
point for Osment's career; he went on to become
a Hollywood icon at the age of nine thanks
to his breakout performance in The Sixth Sense.
He took a break to attend college, and while
his celebrity status has receded, he's not
hurting for work.
He recently reprised his role as Sora in the
third Kingdom Hearts game, and continues to
appear in smaller parts in movies, TV, and
other weird projects.
Character actor Geoffrey Blake portrayed the
loathsome Wesley, Jenny's abusive, bad-news
boyfriend.
He'd already appeared in dozens of movies
and TV shows before Forrest Gump, and he went
right back to that hustle after filming his
part.
You may have seen him in one of his many short
stints on shows like Renegade, NYPD Blue,
multiple CSI series, Criminal Minds, and Grimm.
And while they played enemies on screen, Blake
and Hanks must have gotten along just fine
in real life; Blake went on to film small
parts for Hanks' Apollo 13 and Cast Away.
When Siobhan Fallon Hogan appeared as the
hard-nut-to-crack bus driver in Forrest Gump,
she'd just finished some small but memorable
work in two comedy institutions.
She'd been a cast member on Saturday Night
Live for its seventeenth season in 1991 and
'92, and had a recurring role on Seinfeld
as Tina, Elaine's weird roommate.
Fallon Hogan has played many small parts since,
but she's also a frequent muse of provocative
filmmaker Lars von Trier.
But while she still works as an actor, she
left Hollywood behind long ago, choosing instead
to live in suburban New Jersey with her family.
When a nearly grown Forrest gets chased by
a bunch of bullies in a pickup truck, he's
so fast he manages to outrun them, earning
the attention of legendary University of Alabama
football coach Paul "Bear" Bryant.
Forrest secures a sports scholarship and becomes
a reliable All-American playmaker who's eventually
given the chance to meet President John F.
Kennedy.
JFK may appear in the movie thanks to special
effects, but Bear Bryant is played by a flesh
and blood actor named of Sonny Shroyer.
It's nowhere near Shroyer's most famous work,
though.
Prior to his Forrest Gump part, he played
Deputy Sheriff Enos on the popular TV series
The Dukes of Hazzard.
Shroyer was so likable in the role that he
got his own spinoff series, simply called
Enos, in 1980.
Shroyer was nearly 60 years old when Forrest
Gump was filmed, and his career has understandably
slowed down a bit in the years since.
He tended toward movies with ties to the American
South, including Ray, A Love Song for Bobby
Long, and multiple adaptations of John Grisham
novels.
When Forrest heads to New York City to check
on his old friend Lieutenant Dan, he finds
that his former commanding officer isn't doing
well.
He's found living in squalor, spending most
of his time drinking and cavorting with two
women of questionable repute: "Long Limbs
Lenore" and "Cunning Carla."
"Loser!
Ya freak!"
Marla Sucharetza, the actress who played Lenore,
is presumably a lot nicer than she comes across
onscreen.
Forrest Gump marked her first role in a major
movie, and in its wake, she's had a long career
as a character actor.
She's popped up in TV shows like Seinfeld,
Damages, and The Good Wife, and made multiple
appearances on different Law & Order series.
She also appeared in movies such as The Station
Agent and the crude comedy Road Trip, in which
she was credited as playing a "Sperm Bank
Nurse."
Hey, acting isn't always glorious.
Sometimes you're in a gross-out movie, and
sometimes you're in the cast of a beloved
Best Picture.
"Life is a box of chocolates, Forrest… ya
never know what you're gonna get."
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.